Council adopted the two decisions
confirming that Spain and Portugal
didn't take effective action to decrease
their effect excessive deficit
Commission has 20 days to submit
proposal on implosion of of fines which
can reach up to up to 0.2 percent of GDP
in the meantime with the next day Spain
a protocol can submit day SoCo recent
requests arguing for reduction of the
fines I'm sure that we will have a smart
intelligent result at the at the end the
council formal adapted the anti tax
avoiders directive which prevents
aggressive tax planning issues that
taxes are paid where profits where the
profits are generated we welcome today's
council conclusions on the work of the
Basel Committee on Banking Supervision
we want to ensure that standards
currently being revised strikes the
right balance between being Prudential e
sound and allowing banks to finance the
real economy ministers also discussed as
a Commission's anti-money-laundering
proposal of fifths of July this proposal
has two main objectives first is to
prevent terrorists from assessing the
financing they would need to carry out
their attacks and activities the second
objective is to ensure greater scrutiny
and tighter rules to better identify who
is exactly behind the company's being
used for laundering as a proceeds of
crime or tax fraud and evasion this was
the first echofon since a UK referendum
it is clear that managing post
referendum process or wire difficult
economic and political decisions
longer-term economic consequences will
be to a large extent determined by the
model of cooperation between UK and the
rest of the EU